how do I take ownership of mixed
messages to the people under me from the
other leaders in my group pretty
straightforward question I like it well
first of all you have to address this
straight up with the other leaders in
your group because if you aren't aligned
as a leadership team this is going to
hurt the cause it is absolutely gonna
hurt the cause this is critical and it's
going to be hard and there are some
things in your group that people do not
agree on and that is why they are
undermining the messaging or why they're
giving out different messaging because
they don't agree with it they don't have
the courage to stand up and say hey I
don't agree with this right here so
let's do it a different way here's my
thoughts they don't have to curse do
that so what do they do they just sit
back and then when it comes time to put
out the word they put out the mixed
messages and it's it's a bad situation
and you actually have to lead here
that's what you have to do and it
shouldn't actually be that hard because
what you're asking for is something that
anybody can tell is important so you
know you say this you say to your
leadership team you go hey guys our
message to the troops needs to be
aligned and right now it isn't we need
to fix that is there anyone on your
leadership team is going to disagree
with that no they won't
that's not what they disagree with they
everybody knows that the leadership team
has to have an aligned message they have
to be on the same sheet music and that's
what you need to do and and again it's
going to be a hard conversation it's
going to bring out that statement should
bring out the conversation of what
people don't agree on and why they're
sending missed messages now if you if
you cannot get them aligned it is a
serious problem but if you can't the
best thing you can do is mitigate
mitigate that to your team by becoming
the trusted voice so with your team you
want to become the trusted voice now
this doesn't mean that you can go on
undermine your other leaders and say uh
echo came in here he doesn't know he's
talking about no no no no that's not
what I'm talking about
I'm never almost never talking about
undermining another leader or a
leadership team
what I'm gonna do though is I'm gonna
translate I'm a same hey guys our job on
this I know echo said that here's our
job here's here's what our focus needs
to be here's the way this translates for
us so I'm not disparaging you and I'm
not even disagreeing with you I'm simply
honing the message for my team now you
still even when you do that you're
mitigating that as much as possible you
still have to maintain the critical goal
of getting your leadership team aligned
and one other little tool to help make
that happen is to present their words
back to them mmm
and you said you know I wrote down what
you said to the team this morning and I
just want to go through that with you
and break it down a little bit and and
then go through it line by line and have
the hard conversations and make the
tough decisions you got to make the
tough decisions and also give a little
seed some points right be flexible but
unify unify the message and there's a
worse not even worst case scenario but
there are scenarios where echo and I
cannot agree on the message and we got
to go up the chain of command now I
would never want to do that I would
never ever want to say to my boss hey
echo and I can agree you need to make a
decision for us to me that's a total
failure it's a failure in my leadership
that I can't get us on the same sheet of
music so I don't I can't even think of
any time that I ever did that went to my
boss and said hey boss I can't wait you
know I can't come to come to a
conclusion here with the other tasks in
your commanders I can't come to a
conclusion with the other platoon
commanders or I can't come to the
conclusion with the my squad about how
it is I've never done that
so you should be able to if you're right
you'll win the argument and if you're
wrong didn't you change your mind so
it's not that it's not like this open
not like I'm saying I'm great I'm just
saying if you're right then you'll win
the argument and if you're wrong then
you'll change your mind so it's not that
hard so that's what happens needs to
happen here with the leadership team
we've got
right now who's right and people that a
right need to convince the people that
are wrong now you need to check your ego
obviously across the board everything
everybody on the team's got to check
their ego because a lot of people will
be holding on to their idea because it's
their idea and they love their idea
mm-hmm because their statistical and
that's how I would deal with mixed
messages coming down the chain of
command I'm going to go ahead and just
say it that could have been one of the
best lines I've ever heard if you're
right you win the argument if you're
wrong you'll change your mind that's a
good that's a good one your thing denim
I did just make it up here I mean I
guess it's something that I've known but
right yeah that's what makes it so good
because you kind of kind of seems like
oh yeah you know right but that's never
the case but if your being on the
up-and-up there it is right there